So you can add code to your app
to track how users view products,
add products to the cart, checkout,
and finally purchase their products.
You use two classes to label this kind
of tracking, Product and ProductAction.
The Product instances define a product,
and
ProductAction instances define what
the user is doing with the product.
For example, let's say the user
adds a dinner to their cart.
So they've selected their dinner, and
now they're going to put it in the cart.
You'd create product like this,
new Product().
Set the name, set the price,
set the variant, set the id,
and set the quantity.
And of course, you're app would
actually calculate all these values
at the point at which the user
added the product to the cart.
Then you'd create
the ProductAction like this.
You just create ProductAction and
you specify the action.
In this case, ACTION_ADD indicates that
the user added the product to the cart.
And after you create the Product and
the ProductAction,
you add them both to an event
to send to analytics, like this.
Get the tracker, create the event hit,
set the category, set the label.
And here, we add the product, and
here we set the product action.
So notice that you do these two things.
You associate the product
action with the product
when you create the event hit,
not when you create the product.